but you remind me of it you're like John
Hamm you're like a female black Johnny
and you can't be that cool I'm like it
just doesn't work I'm sorry but thank
you I will take it no one has ever ever
stick around
hey guys want to thank our sponsor
electric e-bike if you're struggling
with what to get your dad this Father's
Day give him the gift of a fun powerful
and easy way to get outside and explore
with his own electric e-bike visit
electricebikes.com to learn more and
explore the Epic models electric has to
offer that's electric
l-e-c-t-r-i-c-e-bikes.com hey Tommys
welcome to another episode of dumb
people Town population
uh Randy and I were just talking before
the show we're like this is what we love
about zainab we love I love the writing
in your stand up we love how calm you
are on stage we love energy great great
energy always great great great energy
it's not fair well you remind me of that
you're like Jon Hamm you're like a
female black Johnny
and you can't be that cool I'm like it
just doesn't work I'm sorry but thank
you I will take it no one has ever ever
you start talking when somebody goes how
you want me to bring you up you say just
the black black John Hamm but both
people we know both people we like both
people who are super talented in so many
ways that it's not fair but welcome
thanks for having me all right so this
is the world that we live in it's a dumb
world and it's getting we're just trying
to joke about it yeah it's the only time
the only way we can do it is beat back
through comedy so I would love it if
somebody's like do you watch the news
like not so much but I listen to dumb
people time yeah people that get all
their news we are a trusted Source we
can't speak for the sources we're using
but we are attracted we're the source
well didn't pad and Oswalt say this is
where he comes to turn off his brain he
listens he's like I listen to so much
politics and stuff and it's just so
charged it's like I I need to not think
about I just want to think about dumb
stories yeah
a story sent in by our friends so our
fans send the stories in you can send it
at school Brothers
dumb people town and this was sent in in
November by Liz Hagerty that's how many
of a backlogs so here's the I'll give
you the there's the headline of the
story ready okay woman reveals why she
married her step-brother
[Music]
so technically I mean I get that it has
some cringe to it but step brother
you guys fell in love that's why it's
just Italian is that is that is that
what you're assuming or do we know that
or do we have to wait to see I hope it's
true she's going to reveal it Dan I
don't know why you're jumping the gun I
don't know maybe her stepbrother is a
billionaire okay fine she did it for
money yeah in which case you're like
come on either way you have to yell Tada
right after you dude
a woman's love story has gone viral
online after sharing how she met her
husband and it's all thanks to their
parents who were married a year earlier
do you think when the parents got
married they're like look we're doing
this for the kids sure we're literally
doing this to get our kids together like
that is the ultimate parent look we're
going to show you how to do it okay
we're doing it you guys do it you sure
you guys don't want your own room
also you just naturally assume like if
you use stepsister or brother you assume
that you grew up in the same I have a
feeling that I think these kids are in
their 30s yeah they're okay we're gonna
guess how old they are we're gonna we're
gonna get to that and I want to do that
hopefully they're both in their 30s yeah
yeah so it's just that when she said
like how we met I'm like clearly you
guys were walking in the hallway yeah oh
hey you live here you were in the
bathroom first yes
all right so Matilda Erickson and will
guess her age later said she never
considered marriage until she met simuli
great name simuli yeah
absolutely Sam let's Sam
let's just stick with us anyway uh
when uh her mom and her dad tied the
knot back in 2019 their friendship took
a turn in 2021 do you want to guess how
long they were friends before they wait
hold on the their parents got married in
2019. okay they got engaged their
friendship took a turn in 2021 2021 so
how long do you think I mean you can
probably do the math is it two years two
years but do you think the parents were
dating ahead of time yeah of course all
right so that's what I wonder like what
if at the wedding they're like he [__]
you look [__] you look great like
just a little bit of open bar energy
like people look good at save it if they
get married in 2018 let's just call it a
two-year year of dating and year of
Engagement they've at least they at
least knew each other for four years you
figure they dated for at least a year so
you think about the step sister and
brother yeah yeah their friendship
lasted your parents got married in 2019
let's say their parents started dating
in 2017. yep
so and they've dated for at least a year
right they got married in 20. well he he
just said that it took a term in 2021 so
we don't know how long they were friends
before I'm asking you guys how long do
you think what is take a turn like yeah
that's what I'm trying you can do anal
now and you're like okay all right all
right I think take a turn means went
from like platonic to Road right right
they hooked up also means anal right
which also means the best thank you the
back door is now open uh wait so how
many years do you think their friendship
was before this happened I kind of feel
like they knew each other for a long I'm
gonna I'm gonna say six years six years
what do you think four years I don't I
don't think that I think it's it's
shorter yeah
like 19. you could have met at the
wedding even if they didn't meet at the
wedding they met a day before at the
rehearsal dinner yeah wait who's this
person it's my daughter and your
soon-to-be sister so you say two years
all right get your answers in town is
because their three-year friendships oh
okay so you're right in the middle of
everybody there are three year
friendship I took a turn when her
stepbrother went in for a kiss so he's
the one who initiated it that is like a
bold so there's you knew I mean there's
a lot of time I guess but like you're a
close family come on that is a bold step
to be like I'm now gonna take this
relationship which is you know sibling
wait a second and their parents are
still married yes
I've never had a guy be like or a
brother
that's very good be like hey sis I'm
gonna walk you to your car and then it
ends with a kid I know come on no she
said I responded right away with passion
so Dan you're right I feel like there
was energy he was picking up he was
acting on something he wasn't like just
blind also in today's world there was a
lot of flirty texts happening right this
is my favorite thing uh I I responded
right away with passion Miss Erickson
told Yahoo news Australia why are you
talking to Yahoo news Australia yeah why
you gotta put this out there yeah
Australia okay it took us how long to
start dating after that and he basically
moved in with me right away how long do
you think three months what do you think
a year no start dating right after the
they started dating right after the
passionate kisses she met with the
ultimate Pastor I mean I'm gonna say six
weeks sorry sorry six weeks he's three
months two weeks after they started
dating yeah and then he basically moved
in with me right away it felt good and
natural immediately okay I'm gonna show
you these are your if these if this is
you and your wife's kids right their
stepbrother and sister aren't you
pulling them both or one aside and be
like this had better feel real I'm not
saying you have to get married but don't
this is not a [__] around because this
is our fault I mean you know don't don't
[__] where you eat you don't mess with
people at work I mean Tiger Woods is
going through this thing right now he
dated a woman that like worked at one of
his restaurants and stuff and it's now
she wants 30 million now she wants 30
million I broke up with her he said
we're gonna take a trip yeah meet you at
the airport yeah I kind of like that
better than getting a text like
I'm just saying there's worse ways to
break up with a person but still I'm
gonna show you the picture and you're
gonna be like you won't believe that
they're step siblings you'll be you'll
be like they look like real siblings
okay okay
they look happy first of all that's
their parent married parents yeah
they're both good looking by the way
yeah
they're both like
they both could meet other people out in
the wild you don't have to look in your
own family for this but home is where
the heart is dude yeah but you know I
feel like this the parents wedding the
parents wedding must be their second
wedding
yeah and I think this is like I
you're behind so I think that there's
less it's not that I'm for it but I'm
not against it and I think that because
if it's real it's real well I think the
stakes are less high like in terms of
like don't mess this up this is not it's
like I think that the stakes are not
like that the parents could be together
and then sure maybe the parents will
break up and the kids will stay together
forever they be the parents will break
up it's a good thing to hope for all
right
parents are happy but friends judge
lately so the parents were cool with it
yeah but the friends judged the
relationship a few days into the
Romantic relationship Miss Erickson from
espoo Finland file this people in the
world file this under [__] happens in
Finland right
in the world though The Girl with the
Dragon Tattoo just got out of a sauna
okay
about 10 kilometers from Helsinki so
it's like an outs the outskirts of else
think he started to feel weird and the
reality of this situation dawned on her
quote I was confused and in love at the
same time and honestly I didn't know
what really know what to do think about
the fact that he's still my stepbrother
and also I thought about other people's
opinions so she didn't like go into it
right like this is what I'm doing and I
don't care about what other people think
she had a little reservation which makes
me like her for two weeks
that's it
and a hard end well and he had a hard on
their parents were the first people they
told about their love for one another
and they were very happy from us with
from the start yeah clearly they
probably felt the energy but I think
zainab's right I think they were both in
terrible relationships that you know
marriages that ended sure and they're
like in a second marriage now they're
like whatever makes you happy because
they've been through life where and
these are adult kids you're right like
they all don't live in the same house
this is less crew we had a story once
where twin brothers married twin sisters
and then they all lived together and
essentially genetically each pair's kids
are the same brothers and sisters yeah
Brothers it's all the same DNA those
people were weird
those people are weirder than this I
agree so his way said I think simuli
again we got to change that can we
please
smooley's dad even kind of hoped that
something like this would happen again I
don't like that energy was Eric said
admitted but their friends reacted to
look at her so get your new stepsister
junk you're drunk I'm getting that ass
25 years old get it at your age some of
our friends were at first a bit doubtful
and were kind of judging I think it was
because of the confusion that someone uh
someone I had been calling stepbrother
is now being called my boyfriend at
first her friend's judgment bothered her
and she started to have doubts but it
was Miss Erickson's mom who helped her
get my thoughts in order okay show me do
whatever I feel was most right in that
moment good advice from a parent okay
right does she call him step boyfriend I
I don't know maybe maybe putting
everything aside and follow my heart and
that led me to Mary simuli in three
weeks I'm kidding no uh she told you she
told Yahoo again stop talking to Yahoo
news right but we both have been in a
few long relationships before but it
never felt like this way I mean that's
also good to know July the ball don't
lie that's also good this isn't like
their fur you know I was 25 and I never
dated anybody yeah and he was there no F
that this is they know by the way this
is why I had a little bit of a problem
with Clueless
it's a great movie but I was like
there's a mom where I'm like you guys
went for it at the end where the I'm
sorry spoiler alert if you haven't seen
it no I saw it I love that movie and I
love that scene and now I feel very
different about this story thank you
yeah I am rooting for simuli and I love
his name now you like it see absolutely
it's like a Hasidic Jew from like
Bensonhurst or it can clean up any
spilled uh liquid that's right
that's like a type of yeah okay I mean
see far be it for me to say like who a
person should love like we shouldn't say
that stuff it's kind I'm happy for them
that they found each other and I'm happy
that the parents aren't giving them [__]
you know what I mean the friends got to
back off this is what it is like they're
unique situation LED them to investigate
it when they first got together they
began researching if steps siblings
could legally marry in Finland so they
checked this out they started Googling
their situation is there anywhere where
it's illegal it shouldn't be it really
should the step is the big
like yeah it's like the difference
between falling and flying both are in
the air but not the same thing that's
right that's one's here the step is all
you need to make it okay yeah you were
brought together by two other people so
once the friends saw their connection I
think they didn't lose any friends
I was gonna say the only the only
difference is like the big thing is that
they met as adults right right the only
difference is if your step siblings that
grow up in the same raised together
raise it that's a little bit weird I
would agree yeah yeah so also you
shouldn't want to do that anyway like go
out be an adult find your own person
it's hard enough to have friends your
whole life who you can change and become
someone I mean this is what I would say
about them if they were my friends and
I'd be curious to hear what you think
these are my friends they followed their
heart uh they don't make every great
choice but they're good people that's
what I would say about them what would
you say about them if they were your
friends I I would just keep going step
step guys step step step I would say
girl why you keep telling people
just it just say
just say Yeah
in my family all right uh so they have
detailed their whole relationship this
is another bad decision they made in a
series of Clips on Tick Tock why did I
not say they look like a tip-tock couple
they do and that's where they receive
the most handsome Miss Erickson in one
video she claims to have people saying
Matt uh nasty things like straight to
jail I'd rather die others said it was
weird if you're putting your thing on
Tick Tock you know anything we put on
social media expect to get yeah no
matter what it is even if it's the best
thing I've ever seen the best of the
only thing you need to know about how
are like people function online is there
are clips of Jay Larson doing his bit
from like 15 years ago and people are
arguing in the comments that the guy in
the video stole this from Jay Larson
that's right
he's in the he's the guy in the video
that's all you know who knows the video
of the little white boy and the little
black boy seeing each other on the
sidewalk little one of the best running
up to each other and hugging each other
do you know this video it's not this
beautiful video ever scroll down and one
of the comments is gay I'm like shut up
shut up derogatory
in a bad thing but like bro yeah these
are two-year-olds yeah that's the
internet you if you put this on the
internet expect that I mean but if you
put something on the Internet captioned
I married my step brother you you're
gonna get it you're inviting it in right
yeah you're welcome it's like you're
trolling actually dude you wanted heat
yeah you want to complain about how hot
it is yeah so it says it's not so but
people gave some good comments it's
honestly not that bad compared to people
dating their cousins oh is it yeah I
guess not right they're not even
biological one is related and one isn't
yeah guys chill out they're not even
related another agreed like honestly
that is so cute your mom marrying his
dad and you marrying him a fourth road
so they're finding people sure all right
so this generally makes me happy I love
this so much says another and to which I
say who cares yeah why would you like
that if that's true let's end it on this
it's kind of a nice story I mean I'm I'm
down with it it's a little stupid but
it's nice all right so how old is she
and how old is he let's start with oh
and we saw them Erickson you saw them so
you have an idea but like how old do you
think she is how old is she yeah let's
do Matilda first I'm gonna go 25 27. I
was gonna go 27 as well so I'll go
go whatever you want
whatever you want
I'll go 24. 24. okay one of you is one
year off do you want to everybody adjust
now
26. all right no 28. you can go we can
both land I'm gonna go 26. 26. you can
say but it won't be 26 because he said
one of us is one year off I said 27. so
she's twenty can't be 26. she's either
23 or 28. so I'm out
yeah Dan you're out yeah what do you
think 23. 28 get chances in townie
because Matilda Erickson is 23 years old
okay now how old is he samuli how old is
simuli you saw him saying everyone go
first
um
I love it she's being very defensive
offensive
because that
remember he's definitely 21. 21 you
think he's younger Rob in the Cradle a
little bit
26. that's exactly what I was going to
say sorry I'll go with you I'll ride it
with you 26. all right you're all right
I'm not even gonna do this T25 27 years
all right so there you go that is it so
it's a story of steps sibling love it's
love this has to be a romance I mean I
know clueless did it but like why isn't
there I feel like this could be a
romantic comedy moving forward oh yeah
right their parents get married and then
they get married actually there's a
romantic comedy out about this it's not
who is starring like a lot of like
people yeah but basically the parents
are having affairs with each like so
that the parents of the bride and groom
they're actually having affairs with
each other they don't know it yeah and
they don't you know and then the kids
have the wedding or family whatever and
then they meet and it's like oh we're
all just like uh so by the way that's
just the reverse of this scenario like
we think it's weird that's that's a
great thing to bring up so let's say you
had I bet that's happened a lot so let's
hear people get married and they each
have a single parent and their parents
meet right later in life right
who would begrudge people that is a
great gnome would be no one would be
Grudge that I love that we started here
with a nice story
um who's next I'm gonna see who's next
in here but when we come back we'll talk
about uh how you can follow zainab and
you know watch her and and check out you
can watch her on the show upload on
Amazon which is amazing we'll talk about
all that on the other side of the break
it's dumb people town with zainab
Johnson we'll be right back boom
hey guys welcome back to the show uh
before we get to how you can support
zainab and and see her live and watch
all of her stuff uh we should mention uh
I don't know when this is dropping not
sure not sure it's probably not gonna
drop but before we go to Minneapolis so
if you came to see us in Minneapolis
which is happening in two weeks thank
you we'll be in San Francisco at Cobbs
Comedy Club uh middle to end of July
21st and 22nd please come see us there
that is a great giant club and it is so
fun in San Fran it's great yeah well
that club is full it's just such a good
so come see us there support us uh by
supporting our patreon for this show uh
we give extra content it's a great way
to support us along the way and uh and I
think that's and on the June 14th we're
doing uh tag it tag is such a fun show
which you should come away we'll ask you
on the air I'm putting on the spot
basically we've done it at festivals he
did in Montreal where our friends go up
and do their material and we're on the
side writing tags and afterwards we
pitch you though we come on stage and
Pitch you tags that you can take away oh
I love that so like it's been great and
people have used the tags Dan used to
tag in this special people have used
tags so it's a really fun June 14th the
belly room at the comedy story in La if
you want to see that show it sold out
last time before we even got up there so
let's figure that out and come see that
Daniel how can people catch you go to
danielvankirk.com by the time this drops
there should be dates announced for
places I'm going to be at the end of
summer and in the fall I'd love to see
you guys come out to that or you can
check me out in Los Angeles
um whether I'm picking up sets at the
store or around town I have my own show
every other Monday best bet is with
Myself and Irene too we just did it let
me show you guys we're great you close
it out so go to danielvankirk.com or at
Daniel Van Kirk on social media all
right zaidab how can people follow you
see your dates and all that other stuff
uh they can see my dates on my website
which is anabjohnson.com z-a-i-n-a-b
Johnson they can follow me on Instagram
Twitter or whatever do it it's a great
phone Johnson yeah on Twitter I mean on
Twitter on Tick Tock I am the zainab
why did someone try to jump in and give
you a zainab Johnson you know what I
actually didn't start my Tick Tock like
somebody else started my Tick Tock I
mean I was able to get it that's great
good yes get it good so I'm not sure how
that happened but yeah I got a lot of
dates on my calendar I don't know when
this is coming out so just just go to my
website and you'll be able to see all
things that I am doing such a great
comedy experience and again like we went
to that we were like warming up for our
Gala sets we were Gala set was amazing
but like when we went to that mall what
looked like a haunted mall let's be
honest we went into that mall to do that
preset remember oh yes yes and I'm like
where what is this [__] this will be
horrible and then the club was so hot
yeah it was so fun and we watched her
set in there and Randy and I were like
that's so good and we were in the back
just loving it loving the whole you and
Caroline Ray I just love both of your
sets two sets in the night and then we
got to see that set in At The Gala at
the galley I have I had fun on that Gala
I missed one word and that's it did you
yeah no one knows but I know you know of
course you do it's so bad God damn it I
know we feel that you feel that way but
I mean we didn't notice we saw both
sessions we were up in the room just so
you know is that when you guys texted me
and said she felt like she was a word
she's a word short I texted Dan I was
like you know that was a good set but I
mean just you know we were up in the
room with all the you know represented
irrepresentation and all the producers
and all those other people and everyone
was loving it and it was very cool cool
so go see her live everybody do that
Daniel you ready to jump yeah let's do
it standing by Ace of Finance at Dragon
ilm okay headline is Tokyo man arrested
for driving without a license pretty so
normal but that's never enough no that's
not enough I mean there's definitely
more to this story like what so okay so
now we sit here I'm like what was he
driving sure why is that man how was he
how was he driving why is that of note
that's right uh he's here he's not in
Tokyo he's in Tokyo oh he's in Tokyo say
Tokyo man it's like Florida man yeah
Tokyo the Florida I don't know yeah what
is in Japan exactly is he a Tokyo
Drifter
on the 15th of May a passenger car was
driving through
higashi murayama that's very good Dan I
tried you did right that's pretty good I
actually think Japanese is like
phonetically you can sound it out pretty
well yeah say it three times though
[Laughter]
he was driving through uh Tokyo when it
was when the passenger car was suddenly
Struck from behind by a Harley-Davidson
three-wheeled motorcycle okay so he's
right Chuck from behind he's got to be
the Harley driver right yeah he has to
be yeah however rather than following
the proper procedure and notifying the
police of the Collision the motorized
tricycle sped off by the way calling it
a motorized tricycle really brings it
down that really like a like a badass
bike or one of those things you're like
I love your tricycle
the eagle in the Harley-Davidson logo
flies away my son has one of those four
dude luckily no one was injured in the
crash but it left a dent in the car that
cost do you guys want to guess how much
yen or US Dollars we can do either one I
don't even know how much yen is to a
dollar that's two dollars okay it's like
100 yen to one dollar right but that one
100 yen equals one dollar oh my God
yeah yeah I have two Japanese names as
of this two Japanese sister-in-laws okay
this is okay don't date them don't they
do or do I don't care oh okay they're
not her stepsister okay uh my nieces
[Laughter]
wait my friend just in that vein a
comedian uh Justin williman who's a
magician I mean he's so funny he was
saying that he when he tickles his son
his son's word to be like stop that's
too much is Uncle so he'll be like Uncle
Daddy and he's like Uncle daddy that
doesn't sound right
like a password to get into a club at
three Uncle Daddy yeah all right okay
what do you want to guess Jan or do you
want to go oh yeah I want to do yeah but
there's not a big like like like it
takes 100 yen for one dollar but they're
they're comparable in terms of worth
okay do you know it's not like a it's
not like 100 pesos yeah
if I'm doing bad math in my hand it's
around one
it's around
10.25 so how much damage was the dent
yeah just the dent just for a goof I
think I mean cars are expensive and like
the dense like you might not even this
isn't even why we're doing this okay
3500 Yen so 350 bucks oh I'm gonna say
30 000 Yen okay so 300 bucks
conversion right you guys are gonna make
fun of me when I tell you both all right
I think it's like about 35 US Dollars 35
it is 400 000 Yen oh which is four
thousand dollars two thousand nine
hundred dollars okay
all right
so the owners of the automobile reported
it to the Tokyo Metropolitan Police the
TMP who launched an investigation into
the hit and run it look
but nobody was hurt right I wish that
there was enough going on that you could
get a cop to investigate a debt in a car
right because that tells you what you
took hit but they look at you and go we
really what do you want a piece of paper
we'll give you a piece of paper or
they're just like we got to get on this
I mean we need to start investigating
this right now the car did have a dash
cam that they used to identify there you
go tricycle there you go it wasn't until
about two months later that the same
silver bike was spotted by a patrol car
in kyose Tokyo they're like we got them
officer tried to pull the suspect over
but he sped off down a narrow path that
the car couldn't enter so that's what I
was gonna say the streets in Japan are
very narrow and the first time I visited
it do we have time in the story yes it
is okay so the first time I visited I
want to go so bad to Japan it's a great
it's like New York in the future well
Tokyo specifically wow but then there's
like whatever it's great
um but the I you know I'm a jaywalker
like just by Nature I grew up in New
York
and it's a very tiny Street in in Japan
where I was and no cars were coming I
mean I waited looked both directions no
cars seven motorcycles no no as soon as
I stepped off the curb every other
person waiting gas oh like what's she
gonna do it made me come back that's
right their reaction brought you back to
the curb yeah I was like oh my God just
because you were breaking out of the
norm of Crossing wherever you want I
guess so whoa so they're very orderly
yes like it's very much a rules
following no no it's two Societies in
one they got crazy rules that everyone
sort of follows and then underneath that
the hidden juice like you can eat people
or like they're so crazy
right at the surface
I went to American Airlines
you didn't go to Spirit Air Japan Spirit
Air Japan's a very different Japan my
friend okay so the car turns down a
street that the car can't fit or the
tricycle does right uh well by the way
what a moment like you described that so
cinematically like I can imagine you
taking this step up everyone around like
what is going on one of the officers
jumped out of the car and followed on
foot eventually catching up to the
motorcycle at a dead end so what seemed
like a great oh you can't follow you
yeah
also the cop to go give me a shot I'm
getting out I got this open run when
police asked to see the Biker's license
he told him that he had left it at home
oh boy however upon further questioning
the writer named tatsuo Matsumoto
finally broke down and admitted that he
had never had a license and he was
arrested without driving license further
investing and like I want this guy to
admit like five more crimes
investigation
that Matsumoto had been operating Moto
bikes in Tokyo without a license for how
long Okay how long do you think up until
this point this guy was like I'm Every
Day Is On The Edge every day is 1992 13
years 13 years okay I'm so shocked and
on the edge of my seat for such a petty
crime I know
Japan to take something you know when
you drive around and you know that your
registration sticker is out on you and
every day you're like do not do not get
it
this person was doing this vomit at
least I will tell you years Dan that is
like everything that's like someone
who's like just a little stressed
sexually active ran out of condoms yeah
yeah and it's like I I don't know when I
get into the store right yeah but
tonight
my stepsister's coming over I got [__]
stop it stop it we're doing anal we're
taking a turn tonight it's like he needs
to have more crimes right because yeah
it turns no license into a high like
that's such a bigger offense right
that's right the cover up he bumped it
up right I say 13 years okay what do you
think 10 years 10 years what do you
think
16. okay okay
22. 52 years what's he doing he had been
driving around Tokyo 40 years without a
license
for 52 years
every day
today can't be the day no wonder he ran
by the way the fact that it's the I'm
sorry the fact that this thing went to a
dead end like to me is like a perfect
metaphor it is you gotta stop now bud
yeah what were you gonna say I'm sorry I
didn't mean to cut you off I was going
to say when he probably first did it you
didn't need licenses well so further
investigation so that's their best yeah
after further investigation he explained
that he had attempted to get a
motorcycle license when he when he see I
had tried this all started okay
but he couldn't pass the written test
despite trying how many times do you
think he tried before he goes [__] it
I'm just gonna live a life oh so this is
a guy who tried to take the testimony
yes multiple times and then eventually
it was like 52 I don't care I screwed
that up every year he's like hey I could
he could have tried to multiply that
with you 10.
six times he's like but couldn't pass
the written test so he gave up near the
the end I don't know if do you guys know
what the show up here it is no that
doesn't give anything okay he gave up
near the end of the showa period despite
that he had been riding motorcycles and
uh since he was young and taught by a
senior classmate when he entered High
School he'd been caught and fined once
for driving without a license around
that time and then once again when he
was in his 50s the three-wheeled Harley
was purchased four years ago from a
dealer uh do you need a license he told
police he wrote it every day except
during bad weather and then he gave the
dealer the same line about forgetting
his license when he purchased the bike
there it is
in Japan three-year-old motorcycle can
be driven with a regular car uh class
driver's license right the motorcycle's
license but he had no license to speak
of so it's a point
as someone oh this person just writes
here and someone who took multiple tests
I can confirm they're quite hard and I
wouldn't disparage anyone no one needs
your phone exactly injecting his own or
her own passing it requires a level of
knowledge beyond what the average driver
retains I will say this one when I got
my California license they were like oh
here you can review this thing online
and it'll just give you all the answers
none of the questions were asked they
started asking questions when you when I
switched over to California that were
like what is the fine for being polar
I'm like I don't know your state that
has anything to do with me operating a
vehicle what what state did you switch
over from Illinois so I switched over
from New York and you did I did have to
take the written test you don't have to
take a driving test right yeah yeah yeah
and I got three I got wrong the amount
that fails you they give you a minimum
and she looked at my test and she said
are you from New York and I said yeah
and she said answer this one again and
then I did and she was like okay now you
passed good for her but there was a
there's questions on there that are very
specific to California this doesn't have
to do with me knowing when to break yeah
yeah or being a good driver so my son's
14 and a half and he's like when I
turned 16 I want to get my license I
want to get my 18 year old doesn't it
but like so I'm already now saying to
him how many car legs do you need to be
behind that car if you're going 40. he's
like I don't know I'm like it's done for
every 10 miles per hour so that's the
question they won't ask you on this test
yeah like all that stuff and like I'm
how old do you guys think Tatsu is how
long has he been doing this 52 years
16. yeah I mean 68 okay 72.
70 right on the nose 69 years old
that's Story number two okay
I just to me the dumbest thing in there
is every day carrying that little piece
of stress with you that's nothing
if somebody runs into you you're [__]
like ah I just couldn't no thanks too
much stress yeah uh it's too much
looking over your shoulder give us a
hint what are we looking at after the
break Florida man being a Florida man
okay perfect could be literally anything
yeah I mean floor man acting like a
Tokyo man dude
dude the stories always travel around
the world no I mean yeah they'll be
anywhere anywhere or they could all be
in Ohio or all Florida yeah usually they
all are Florida all right we got zainab
Johnson's with us we got one more story
let's get to this right after the
breakdown people Town don't go anywhere
[Music]
if you are struggling with what to get
your dad this Father's Day give him the
gift of a fun powerful and easy way to
get outside and explore his own world
with electric e-bike sure you could
stick with the same old tie pocket knife
I don't want that beer themed tie hat
whatever why not switch it up with a
gift that he will want to use every
chance he gets can I can I tell you guys
why I know you should do this yes please
I have one it's the greatest it is
life-changing yeah it is life-changing
we took we I mean I and then my family
we use you and you and the electric guy
I took it up to the family cabin in
Wisconsin it has changed everything
about my summer it has changed
everything about the cabin we dude first
of all you can go like over a hundred
miles on them so once it's fully charged
like you don't need to worry about it
yeah it's also very compact so you can
go to Yahoo's into town
it's got the speed for it yeah uh but
the best thing for me me and my family
is you hop on this and then you just go
on down to the lake you can get little
like compartments to carry some of your
stuff with you and then when my family's
down there you zip on back up every
single person Dan we forgot the drinks
they're still back up in the garage
electric baby they really they are
wonderful and it will whoever you give
this to you're gonna end up using it as
much as they are or at least wanting to
I absolutely love it and the great thing
is you can tell by looking at it you're
like oh this isn't just some like
throwaway qual like low quality this is
like high-end looks really good but also
isn't isn't gonna like are you outside
more are you outside more because of
this bike oh yeah dude it makes you want
to be out in the world so what I love
about electric also is that the electric
e-bikes offers a wide range of you can
customize things adjustable e-bike
options to accommodate an array of
different Lifestyles as Dan's talking
about do it this way somebody else
friends of ours have them and they drive
like up into like Griffith Park and go
around there and it's been
especially in the summer so here's what
we're gonna say skip the played out
gifts this Father's Day and give the
gift of adventure with electric e-bikes
visit
electricebikes.com to learn more and
explore the Epic models electric has to
offer that's electric e-bikes
l-e-c-t-r-i-c-e-bikes.com
[Music]
all right everybody I'm gonna take you
home let's do this story sent in by Jake
Rooney at jaycaroney on Twitter long
time friend of the show love this kid uh
here's the headline naked greased up
Florida you could have stopped at the
first two words drove a motorcycle
without a license that's how we do it
here getting greased up you better be a
stupid 18 year old who thinks it's cool
to be in a frat so that is the only
excuse I will give you dumb youth that
they said it's some tradition and you
were stupid enough to think you should
do it we're naked and greased up you
could be like sexy wrestling yeah that's
right yeah you could be like you're
prepping for I don't know you're
prepping for something yes whatever yeah
I suppose you could be naked and greased
up on the set of an adult film and I'm
like okay this is all tracks the olive
oil wrestlers yeah yeah or you could be
like naked and greased up your next word
should be like I'm ready honey I'm ready
come in I did what you asked me to do
here I come all right so naked Grease
the Florida man accused of breaking into
two homes jumping in pool
you got to get the grease up I know now
he screwed up the pool those pool have
to be drained yeah come on all you
needed was some Dawn soap is that right
to Berry Florida a man was arrested
Friday morning in DeBary after he
allegedly broke into two homes and tried
to evade deputies by jumping in a
swimming pool where you gonna go man
they won't see me I'm underwater yeah I
mean you can't swim off the property
there's no yeah you're just doing a lot
of jumping into the ocean like this this
listen you literally just jumped in I'm
so stuck every time you say DeBerry I'm
like the baby
baby Florida or the baby did this all
right so Debary Florida he tried to
evade deputies by jumping in a swimming
pool and onto a trampoline all while
naked according to sheriff so he just
wants to have fun you know what he's got
a bucket list before he gets locked up
he just probably was like I love the
wind against my junk let's go Marco just
get
[Laughter]
we can see you we're not closing our
eyes deputies say they responded around
what time what time do you think they
responded two houses
he did the pool in the trampoline
running from the cops he'd already done
the two houses yeah to a report of a
burglary at a home on high Banks both
things you are not running away from
Cops you were just participating in
something stationary on the property I
feel like this is 5 p.m I think it's
more like 11 A.M 11 A.M 5 p.m
2 A.M 2 A.M one of you is exactly right
oh do you want to decide I'll stick with
me I'm gonna stick with me yeah all
right get your answers in because
at 2 A.M
last financial report uh we'll get to
how old he is at the end uh Blake
tokeman that tells you his age range
right there Blake tokeman tells you his
name and what he does yeah does it um
rapper from Regional rapper from 1997.
man who does like Rasta and dubstep
come on yeah I'm on okay Volusia County
or Volusia County Sheriff's Office said
tokeman smashed out a window to break
into one home then left and broke into
another house deputies say then it
doesn't say really what he took yeah
like he just broke into the home to
break into the home and then go to the
pool oh he could have just kept thinking
they were his right is this my house oh
no it's not let me do another one all
right deputies say they encounter
talking at the second house body worn
camera video released between the first
house called right that's right shows
token running from the deputies jumping
into a pool then climbing out of the
pool then jumping onto a trampoline kind
of on them for letting him get out of
the pool that's right he's in a hole got
him fan out and he's wet and weighed
down also the problem you know there's
always that part where you're either
gonna fall back in the pool or get out
yeah unless you're doing the ladder or
the steps also you couldn't grab him at
that crucial moment when your belly's on
the ground getting out of the pool do
you mean the cops grab them or the
homeowners they're there for the pool so
here's the question how many deputies
did it take to grab this guy he was that
that's what I'm saying
first second or last I'll let you pick
five five I think there were seven
deputies there
I'll go three
four deputies uh who kicked or hit the
deputies one of the deputies was cut on
the arm in addition to being naked the
sheriff's office said token was covered
in wheel bearing Greece that's that is
peppermint oil oh that's kind of you got
that from the first house and blood of
course uh they believe they believe he
may have been under the influence of an
unknown substance no [__] you think yeah
you may buy this way you know what that
one's jumping in the pool that's just I
feel like that's just fun you know what
that upknown substance is heartbreak
yeah yeah she's not coming back or maybe
I don't know maybe his body was burning
or something like what was the
temperature like to be in that is that
thick grease that he was in yeah yeah
well that maybe
I mean that's super super yeah maybe he
was just burning and was like I gotta
get in there
yeah I just picture him getting arrested
and yelling like Halle Berry and
monsters ball make me feel something
that made me feel
and then just does like flip yeah you
think they were like hey man if you want
to get back to the pool for we'll give
you three minutes you want to get back
in you want to swim around and you can
do one Cannonball it's like the end it's
like his end to Point Break but come on
man where am I gonna go the other end of
the pool but you know what sucks it's
like he could have also knocked on your
door you know like the hassle is like
you did all of this and now we got to
replace a window and there's so much I
know you're thinking of the Home Alone
you feel violated because we didn't
accept you into the house yeah yeah
boom or yes the kids never use it three
years ago by the way you see a naked
greased up guy who come to you I don't
have it I want to tell you the type of
parents that are so over it or just like
yeah
someone's use
and then the guy there's a wiffle ball
set in the garage that he hasn't touched
in five years you want to play with that
took me three he's now telling the kid
guy took me three weeks to put that
trampoline together you think the kids
use it go ahead jump all you want just
balance that pool thank God somebody's
using it yeah and the wife runs out we
got some boxers
he's having fun I'm like these [__]
who just sit on their iPad yeah you just
open the door and you go are you violent
no I'm on another plane of existence
fine
just have fun kids you see that's how we
use the pool okay uh token faces charges
of two counts of occupied burglary three
counts of battery on a law enforcement
officer two counts of criminal mischief
one of our favorites and three kinds of
being in the pool I think it should be
three counts yeah right yeah that would
be great do you want it there is a
little video but I don't know if it's
worth watching but uh I want to see it
I'll I'll try to get to the video hold
on but first let's guess how old this
how old is token
lake is a young person I love your
reasoning here
I'll go last okay I think I like your
reasoning I think he's 29. I'm gonna go
22. hmm
I'll go 25 no 25. all right get your
answers in this has been a beautiful
episode with you we'll look at the video
uh check out zainabjohnson dot yeah
there'll probably be a link in the
YouTube description or the video might
get thrown in either way you'll be able
to either way you can follow and she's a
great follower go see her live follow
her Instagram follow the zainab Johnson
on Tick Tock and uh whatnot but uh just
do it just do it this is our friend
you'll be like hey I was on that train
as it as it's blowing up and doing all
it does all right this cat Blake talkman
who was naked and jumping on a
trampoline and jumping in a pool is 34
years old wow older old enough to know
yes no matter thank you 34 yeah he's 30
yeah no one here said he was in his
third I'm trying to go by his video but
it's not it's not all right we'll do it
in post we'll show it all right we'll
show it in public we'll show it to each
other all right that's a show you what a
beautiful show thank you for coming to
do it this is such a treat thank you so
much for having me a wonderful romp all
right zainab Johnson thank you and guys
oh [__] we gotta get back to work bye
stick around
[Music]